miny theory what if all Dumbo's problems
were just the result of the stork at the
beginning of the movie delivering him to
the wrong mother
Dumbo's ears are certainly much bigger
than the other elephants in the circus
but they don't look so absurd when you
look at the size of African elephants
ears now look at all the other elephants
that you see in the circus they have
themselves smaller ears making it likely
that their Asian elephants does that
mean Dumbo is actually a case of
mistaken identity where is it a
commentary on cultural migration and
racial tension is Dumbo actually super
woke nope back to the drawing board
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that
proves the theorist much like an
elephant never forgets to overanalyze
that is with the recent release of Tim
Burton's part live-action part CGI
all weird version of Dumbo I've been
thinking about Disney's iconic original
from 1941 no I respect this movie for a
lot of reasons but today I respect it
mostly firts brevity it's rare that I
get to do a film theory on a movie that
is only 64 minutes long end game love
you but you're gonna have to build in a
pee break or find an editor who can make
some hard choices take a lesson from
Dumbo here friend brevity is next to
godliness and keeping it brief is
probably the best thing for Dumbo since
you know it's a movie loaded with racial
stereotypes
anyway with this new version out I
decided to take a stroll down memory
lane and re-watch the original Dumbo to
find out that well it hasn't necessarily
aged perfectly he really was a
trailblazer for the Disney canon it's
the first Disney movie centered around
talking animals it's the first one
that's actually set in America believe
it or not and it's the first one with a
psychedelic hallucination sequence
something that would become a staple of
Disney movies for years to come now if
you don't remember the scene first off
do you even world war two bro yeah 1940s
get with it anyway the set up is this
the clowns and Dumbo circus are partying
and drinking champagne you know normal
clown's stuff and they accidentally
knock a bottle of champagne into a large
bucket of water
later when Dumbo and his friend Timothy
Q Mouse wander by Dumbo and Timothy take
a couple of sips and start to feel a
little bit woozy
Dumbo blows bubbles from his trunk then
a few moments later they start seeing
shape-shifting elephants that look like
a Lisa Frank inspired nightmare
the next morning Dumbo and Timothy wake
up in a tree not knowing what happened
the previous evening indicating that
they had just had themselves an alcohol
induced blackouts
I guess the scene was included to show
kids the
of drinking or the magic of drinking
again these were weird times back in
Disney canon so maybe we don't speculate
on the motivation behind showing this to
kids instead just going with the fact
that it's a weird moment that raises
some really weird but also some
fascinating theoretical questions so yes
today I am answering the question that
no one has thought to ask in over 60
years of this movie being out to the
public what is actually happening here
is it possible that Dumbo a baby
elephant is actually getting himself
Shiu stood at basically toddler age I
mean I'm no expert on alcohol but this
scene seems insane and I think I can
scientifically disprove that this could
ever happen in fact I have a theory
about this that instead of being drunk
there's a real-world explanation for
what's really going on with Dumbo here
and that there's actually something very
fishy going on in that buckets so over
the teeth past the gums look out
theorists here it comes to start off
with I was suspicious that an elephant
would ever drink alcohol but this is the
one point that Dumbo actually has going
for it elephants actually like booze
this is not even a joke even in the wild
elephants are particularly attracted to
fermented fruit of the marula tree and
there are even some records of elephant
binge drinking Majuli a strong fruit
wine made in India still there are a
surprising number of Google search
returns that debunk the idea that
elephants like to get drunk at least
regularly so while the taste of hooch
won't turn an elephant off they're not
exactly at the level of college kids on
spring break so don't bow might enjoy
himself the taste of his watered-down
bucket of champagne but if we look at
that scene there is legitimately no way
he drinks enough to actually get as
sloppy as we see him get Timothy Q Mouse
is giving him water to get rid of the
hiccups
so Dumbo sucks up a few trunk fools
holds his breath and then swallows he
doesn't come anywhere near downing the
whole bucket which also means the amount
of champagne he's drinking isn't
anywhere close to the entire bottle even
though the scene makes it seem like he's
just downed himself a whole keg it's
gonna be hard to get a perfect
calculation of just how much Dumbo is
drinking and how that should actually
affect his body but even if we're as
generous as possible we're not gonna get
a result that makes Dumbo's hallucinate
and black out make a lick of sense for
instance a normal bottle of champagne is
750 milliliters about the volume of two
cans of soda
that's roughly five servings of alcohol
now on the other side baby elephants
weigh in at roughly 230 pounds for
context my little baby boy was 130th the
size of a baby elephant the point here
is that if we use a BAC calculator to
say Dumbo weighs approximately 230
pounds and drinks that entire bottle of
champagne in just those couple of gulps
which again he doesn't but devil's
advocate here his blood-alcohol
concentration would be at about point
one one percent at a BAC of 0.11% Dumbo
would definitely be feeling his liquor
and probably shouldn't be driving or
flying but he's nowhere near the insane
levels of intoxication that we see in
the movie according to the American
addiction centers lack outs begin to
occur at blood alcohol concentrations of
0.2 percent and higher or about twice as
high as our estimate for Dumbo now
unfortunately we can't get any more
precise than that because I wasn't able
to find any scientific studies about
getting baby elephants totally hammered
I mean geez science get on that no I can
guess that you're saying to yourself
that it's not fair to calculate baby
elephant drunkenness based on human
limitations we're even human physiology
baby elephants may have a totally
different body composition that could
make Dumbo respond differently to
alcohol and to that I say you are both
astute and also incorrect yes you are
absolutely right to think that the body
composition of a baby elephant isn't the
same as a 22 year old frat bro even if
they do weigh about the same that said
the main body tissue that effects
alcohol absorption is fat where higher
body fat percentages correlate to higher
BAC
since fat tissue is relatively low in
water and can't dilute the alcohol in
your system surprisingly though baby
mammals are actually born with very low
body fat percentages now you might not
believe that because human babies look
like little chubby bunnies and you're
right but human babies are actually the
chubbiest of most of the animals in the
kingdom at about 15% body fat all of
which is clearly going to the legs or as
I like to call them the little chunker's
just those little chunker's our little
Jokers
elephants on the other hand max out at
about fifteen percent body fat as adults
meaning that it's reasonable to assume
that a bottle of champagne wouldn't have
any more effect on Dumbo and a 200-pound
dude and probably more accurately even
less so what gives
why does Dumbo seem so drunk in the
scene is this just cartoon logic well
yeah probably more often than not that's
usually the real explanation but we
don't care about real explanations here
we come up with theories to justify why
it's actually happening as though it's
really happening we want real world
answers for these really inebriated
pachyderms so if you go back and
actually look at the scene what happens
in it it becomes apparent that something
else is likely going on here sure a
bubble comes out of his nose his eyes go
a little sleepy like and he generally
seems to be a happy mellow drunk which
is one of the best drugs so good on you
Dumbo but then you see that immediately
after he takes a drink he starts seeing
hallucinations of pink elephants then
all of a sudden we enter a Dumbo bizarre
averse but guess what alcohol doesn't
make you loosening if we go back to the
scale from the American addiction
centers that describes what happens to
the body at various BAC s it confirms
that your brain will literally start to
shut down before it starts making up
anything like a pink elephant and for
those of you who are the stickiest of
sticklers yes there are a couple of
liquors that have historically been
thought to have hallucinogenic
properties stuff like absinthe but
remember that we know Dumbo is drinking
champagne that is not what's going on
here so what is going on here well it
turns out there's another way to explain
the crazy things that Dumbo and Timothy
Q Mouse see to figure out what that is
we need to look closer at what the heck
was going on in those hallucinations did
you know that not all hallucinogens are
created equally they're actually split
into three major categories psychedelics
dissociatives and deliriums
now the control freak who gets nervous
about taking too many ibuprofen for a
headache so the information I give you
about hallucinogens is rooted squarely
in my research and not in my own
personal experiences so take that for
what it is because judge you BAE
the first category psychedelics include
the things that all the hippies wrote
songs about back in the 70s before
immediately going to rehab stuff like
LSD shrooms peyote those psychedelics
enhance or alter things that are real
like seeing the colors or shapes in a
picture changing or blending
dissociatives like ketamine or nitrous
oxide are associated with the feeling of
stepping out of your own body or like
you're dreaming but you know that you're
powerless to stop in which honestly
sounds like the worst experience ever
but again you do you internet deliriums
aren't generally used on purpose because
they cause nightmarish swings in mood
and extreme confusion that they would
never be considered fun remember a trope
a belladona the poison that we concluded
was in Snow White's Apple back in that
past Theory a trope a belladona is
actually a deliriant it's not good stuff
you don't want to be messing around with
it so what's Dumbo gotten himself into
given that his dream sequence in the
movie starts with real bubbles that
Dumbo has been blowing which then
proceeded to shift in shape and color
the likely a substance that Dumbo and
Timothy have consumed is a psychedelic
the one that morphs what you're already
seeing that limits our list of possible
substances way down to about 5 since
most psychedelics are derived from just
a small number of plants so now let's
look into some history Dumbo is set in
Central Florida around 1941 but common
psychedelics like LSD weren't
synthesized in a lab until 1943 and
would have been very unlikely to end up
anywhere near Dumbo so what we're really
looking for here is a naturally
occurring substance probably a plant
that makes mescaline a possibility until
you consider that it's derived from the
peyote cactus and Central Florida is not
a native home to that particular cacti
nor do we ever see a cactus in the film
but there is a psychedelic that can grow
in the wild in the same area that we're
looking at in Dumbo it's called
psilocybe cubensis aka the magic
mushroom these mushrooms grow naturally
in the wild including in Florida they
have psychedelic effects and they don't
require a large dose to actually get
those effects literally it's just a
grammar to it the stuff and it causes
Lenti of hallucinations now you might be
saying that all of this is
circumstantial evidence I mean just
because Dumbo
experiences the effects of consuming a
psychedelic mushroom that can grow in
the wild near his circus doesn't really
mean a whole heck of a lot it's not like
there's any reason to believe that those
mushrooms would be more likely to be in
and around his particular circus right
wrong you see psilocybe cubensis is
what's known as a copra Phylis fungus
layman's terms likes to grow and poop
the way these fungi reproduce is that
they release their spores through the
air to land on nearby vegetation which
when eaten by herbivores gets completely
passed through their digestive systems
and then out the poopy end for the
mushrooms then grow in whatever comes
out so what would be a great place for
psilocybe cubensis to grow a circus that
houses elephants and hippos that are
eating tons and tons of vegetation
thereby creating more and more spores
that water bucket that Dumbo and timothy
drink from has been sitting outside heck
it even looks pretty dirty in the movie
that happens to be in the perfect
habitat for psychedelic mushrooms and
with the optimal growing conditions for
the mushrooms around it honestly I'd be
more surprised if that water weren't
contaminated with some hallucinogen and
it's certainly no surprise the Dumbo
gets himself a bit trippy after chugging
a few trunk fools so there you have it
friends Dumbo isn't drunk it is simply
not believable that he would black out
after a few sips of diluted champagne
water instead he just got himself the
wrong end of a potent little mushroom oh
and uh next time that you're in Florida
or when you hear about something crazy
going on down there like someone chasing
people around a gas station with an
alligator it might not be their fault
after all there is something in the
water down there but hey that's just a
theory
oh wait a minute are we sure that Dumbo
can even fly what if the whole audience
is hallucinating oh my god the bitter
irony of this whole thing is that it's a
children's movie a Disney animated
children's movie and yet I guarantee
this video gets D monetized for talking
about it it's not our fault that times
have changed people